hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
kind of like Captain America Civil War
week but there's big Avengers infinity
ward news the same people that are
making captain america civil war are
making infinity war they just announced
that they're going to be changing the
titles of infinity War part 1 and 2
because it's a little misleading both of
those films are going to be very
different it's not going to be like one
film cut into two parts so this is going
to be my fun video for all my favorite
alternate titles that I think they
should go with and if it wasn't clear
spider-man is definitely coming back he
will have a new suit that's the only
thing they've confirmed about his
involvement in the film but if you've
seen captain america civil war i think
he'll fit into Avengers infinity war the
same way he fits into civil war like
he'll be a really big deal but he's not
going to be the central character so
that would be so amazing spider-man
wearing the Infinity Gauntlet but
totally never gonna happen if you've
seen the way marvel typically subtitles
its films like they don't do Captain
America 3 the new captain america civil
war you can kind of guess the direction
they're going to go in it needs to be
generic enough so that somebody who's
never seen a comic book before could
look at the title and kind of guess what
the theme of the film is like Civil War
all about an internal battle very easy
to understand so for all of these pics
Avengers has to appear in the title it
has to be the first word in the title so
it's Avengers dot dot dot so really easy
pics if you've never read the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline so we have Thanos
quest Infinity Gauntlet than infinity
war then infinity crusade after that
there are a lot of infinity titles for
Marvel I think whatever the title ends
up being whether it be two words three
words four words even more than I don't
think they'll go with more than four
words Avengers in infinity will both be
in there so really it's just a question
of what that other word is but in like
the first part of the classic infinity
saga Thanos finds out where all the
infinity gems are there in possession of
the elders of the universe obviously in
the Marvel movies that's a little bit
different because vision is definitely
not one of the elders of the universe
but he has the mind gem same thing for
all the other infinity gems so the first
part of infinity war needs to be a movie
where Thanos assembles all the gems
where he goes around assembles them
probably assembles the gauntlet by the
end of that movie and then the ACT break
is him doing something really crazy than
infinity War part 2 whatever that title
ends up being is the Avengers fixing all
the derps so still talking about the
first time
Marvel could just go straight up and
call it Avengers infinity gauntlet and
that would be the name of the movie it's
not a super aggressive title like it
doesn't scream oh my god I gotta go see
this like Civil War is a very action or
in a title the name war is in the title
it tells you exactly what's going to be
happening in the movie so I think that
they would use infinity war for the
second movie so I think that'll actually
stay the same they'll probably just
change the title of the first film
because there won't be as much war as
there will be assembling infinity gems
so Avengers infinity quest Infinity
Gauntlet both really solid picks I'd
also say Avengers first Thanos to be
great title but it doesn't leave room
for infinity to be in there and I think
they want to avoid any comparisons to
Batman V Superman so no V in the title I
think they're just trying to sidestep
that land mine infinity crusade is also
a really good title but that story was
kind of a sequel to the first infinity
saga with Thanos so I don't know if they
would jump straight to that it's a
completely different story line with a
completely different antagonist it's
more of an Adam warlock story and thus
far the films have avoided him I know
everybody wants him to be star-lords dad
but I don't know if they'll go in that
direction most of the guardians of the
galaxy two star-lord add videos that
I've done have been leaning more in the
direction of Eternals and star fox or
eros of Titan who's one of Thanos his
brothers we can start talking more about
that when we get through captain america
civil war annihilation conquest was
really big storyline from the comics
that they could borrow from that was
actually the storyline they got the
guardians of the galaxy to assemble in
the first place it was a storyline that
came after the Avengers had shot Ultron
into space Ultron kind of assimilates
the Phalanx like this cybernetic culture
and they go into this huge war with the
Kree Empire so it's like you know very
guardians of the galaxy oriented type of
story but I think with the Marvel movies
they're going to try and keep it
relatively simple it'll be Thanos his
minions vs The Avengers and eventually
the guardians of the galaxy they say the
Peter quill will team up with the
Avengers I don't know about the other
members of the guardians of the galaxy
but definitely Peter quill so last big
pick not very likely but Avengers secret
wars would be a really awesome title but
I don't think that they would be able to
get that may be the culmination of what
starts with phase 4 if they could do
Secret Wars but if you read secret wars
in the comics they use that is the big
event to retool their comic book
universe so I think Marvel is going to
do
the same thing with infinity war in the
movies is going to use it to reset a lot
of things change characters up introduce
new characters just wipe the slate clean
so that when they start with phase 4
they can go in a new direction with the
movies they don't have to be completely
chained to the stuff that they did
before and if they want to keep
everything in continuity they can still
do that too but I think we can probably
agree that infinity War part 1 is going
to be retitled to infinity gauntlet
Avengers infinity gauntlet and they'll
retitle infinity War part 22 just
infinity war so you get Avengers
infinity gauntlet it'll be Thanos
assembling the gauntlet then you'll get
infinity war it'll be the Avengers and
the Marvel Universe rallying against
Thanos to fix everything that he's done
but let me know in the comments even if
they're just like a fun title what would
you want them to do like deadpool vs
santos is a really good comic they did
recently where deadpool gets his hands
on the Infinity Gauntlet it was
completely ridiculous it's not really
considered canonical you can't really
consider with the main series because a
lot of Deadpool stories like that the
crossover titles are just meant to be
like really fun stories off in their own
little world but even though I think
it's going to be a long long time before
we ever see Deadpool in the Marvel
Universe in the movie universe they
might get to the place where they can
make subtle jokes and references to it
mostly visual references there are a
couple different levels of easter eggs
one like the really biggest easter egg
is when you put an actual character in a
movie that's walking around you cast an
actor for it next step down for that is
if a character references something else
like they reference Doctor Strange
during winter soldier the lowest level
of easter egg is if there's like a
picture on a wall behind a character or
there's like a logo or there's a name on
a list so maybe Fox and Marvel can get
to the place where they can you know
make subtle references to each other
like Deadpool can make fun of the
Avengers in the Deadpool movies the
avengers could put Wade Wilson's name on
a list somewhere but give me all the
most ridiculous Avengers infinity war
alternate titles you can think of this
has really done more on the spirit of
fun I think we all kind of agree the
actual title they go with is going to be
a variation on Infinity Gauntlet an
infinity war and I'm hoping that Marvel
has a little bit of fun when they start
marketing this like they put up all the
fake names that they thought about
calling the movie like you know Deadpool
quest Deadpool vs. Thanos Deadpool and
Thanos vs The Avengers Avengers totally
f'd part 1 that in related fun news
giveaway time can grab
relations to the captain america
giveaway Keegan Fitzgerald you win a
gift certificate for two imax tickets to
captain america civil war really it's a
gift certificate so you could use it for
whatever movie you want but you would be
a fool to not use it for Captain America
Civil War so please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I get
your contact details and because I'm
going to be doing a whole bunch of
Captain America Civil War videos I'll
keep doing the giveaway so the next
round will start the next time I post a
marble video i do have agents of shield
that i'm still working on so that should
post by tomorrow morning while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my flash video from last
night there was a whole bunch of
flashpoint stuff that happened and you
can click here for all my captain
American Civil War videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you